uh very good morning to you Mick Lynch
thanks so much for talking to us this
morning first of all I wanted you to
give us an update on the talks last
night as I understand at the rail
Minister Hugh Merriman was there in
network Rail and the rail delivery group
was any progress made
yes the Royal Minister convene those
talks so we attended as invited as with
the other parties we had an exchange
about what might be possible and uh away
you know some ways forward and ideas
that all the parties shared and the the
rail Minister requested that all the
parties get down to some more
discussions uh in the in the next period
we'll look to arrange those meetings
with the employers and see if we can
develop some solutions to the to the
issues that hopefully all the parties
can support but there were no actual
negotiations there were some soundings
out of what might might be developed so
we'll look forward to getting around the
table with the employers uh and work it
up and see what we can do but there is
no actual there are no new proposals on
the table as we speak
tight amongst the workers themselves to
strike a deal this after the tssa union
accepted Network rails uh pay offer
you've rejected that deal one that the
tssa has accepted why have you rejected
when they think it's adequate
well the tssa and United are minuscule
in network rail we've got eight or nine
times their membership and they're not
affected by the changes that Network
rail which is to make they're generally
not out in the track in all weathers
they're not actually doing the work they
are supervisors and why collar workers
they don't do the work that our members
do who are profoundly affected by the
changes including the safety regime as
will be the public so it's a completely
different set of workers for them it's
essentially a clean no strings deal
there's some minor amendments to their
their work life balance and so on but
ours our members have got completely
different set of terms and conditions
inherited from the private sector which
doesn't really affect them so whether
they're in the in the dispute or not
doesn't really affect the course of
dispute and for our members the the
proposals are completely inadequate at
this time but we'll keep working with
network rail and the talks in order to
get some solutions and that's what we're
aiming to do over the next period so as
you say a different situation for
different unions but does it make your
job harder when other unions accept the
same offer
well they're independent unions they're
I mean I'm not involved in those unions
it's up to them they make their
decisions if they want to get out of the
dispute and accept what's what's on the
table for them that's up to them but the
offer for us is a different offer they
have a different collective bargaining
arrangement for some of their members
and as I say they're not affected by
these changes it doesn't really affect
our members whether the tssa are in this
or not these are the people that
supervise our members they're not really
the people that are affected by the
changes so we'll keep working it up on
behalf of our people it's often away on
the railway that the rmt has to lead
and others follow or drop out of the
disputes at early stages that's been the
way for
a century and a half so far so we'll
probably continue into the future
this is the start of the second 48-hour
strike this week more planned next week
in the run-up to Christmas so what would
it take now to call off off those
strikes next week
all resolutions to disputes are about
compromises we understand what the
companies want and they understand what
what we need so we need some compromise
on some of the conditions they're
putting on the offer and we'll need an
improvement in the payoffer that is
achievable in my view and in the view of
my negotiating team are my executive
committee I also think it's probably the
view of the company so we need the the
government to facilitate that and use
their good offices to get a deal I'll be
working on documents and papers with the
companies if that's what they want to do
with me and then we'll try and get a
solution but there is there is an
agreement there to be had and we'll keep
working on that and try and get to a
position where we can put those
proposals to our members and ultimately
our members will decide whether the two
sets of proposals are acceptable to them
or not
you say there's agreement there to be
had are you feeling any more optimistic
I'm always optimistic I have to be
optimistic in order to get a deal I know
that there are some very simple steps
that the employers and ourselves could
take together to get a solution to this
and that means a common sense approach
uh both sides get into a position where
there's a some commonly held uh
positions and I think we can do that in
the next period And if that is done very
quickly we can consider the industrial
action going forward and of course if we
get a set of documentation and a pay
proposal that our members want to
support it will resolve the dispute and
we can take all of the action away I
hope we can do that as quickly as
possible
a lot of people worried about those
strikes next week they're worried about
how to impact their Christmas plans can
you give us any specifics about what it
will take to call off those strikes next
week
well we'll deal with that with the
government the strikes next week as it
start on Christmas Eve during the wind
down of the Railway uh are about the
engineering works at Network rail are
carrying out when the railway is closed
so there's a full week now between now
and that period if Network rail want to
work with us on some solutions we can
consider that but you know there are
some very straightforward things that
they can do some very straightforward
things they can do to the pay proposals
and to the changes that they want and
they're all getting to deep discussions
with them if that's what it takes and
the minister clearly asked us to do that
in the next period And if we can get
some solutions I can't negotiate with
Skye on the television I've got to do
that in a room with the employers
because that's where meaningful talks
happen and some of that stuff is quite
technical it's about rostering it's
about the way that the people are
deployed it's about their skill sets
it's about safety on the railway so
we'll do that with them and if they can
come towards us a little bit we can
maybe work up some solutions
are you worried though that action at
Christmas will lose you public support
well the public is with us we I get lots
of messages of support we get support
when we're out on our picket lines we
know that the public will be upset and
even angry about the disruption some of
that anger should be put towards the
government and the companies we believe
but the disruption for people on these
strike days that are happening actually
happening at Christmas will be minimal
the railway shuts down on Christmas Eve
in any case to do engineering works
there aren't scheduled trains on
Christmas day nor on boxing day and the
railway curtails its activities early on
Christmas Eve that will be a little bit
earlier than usual but people have got
time now to make plans and I hope that
they're successful in that and that we
can progress these talks to maybe get
some Solutions in the next week or so